[Music]
million kilometers from earth underneath
the cold
seas of europa a horrifying and
vastly intelligent creature lurks
can our human minds even comprehend
such an alien creature
actually yeah it turns out it's a lot
like an octopus
can europa support life
would we go looking for it
and how crazy do we sound right now
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if octopus-like creatures inhabit europa
okay we promise you we haven't
completely lost our minds
the idea of octopus-like creatures
inhabiting europa
comes from open university professor of
planetarian space science
monica grady she says that below
europa's ice sheets aliens that resemble
octopuses may dwell that gets the
imagination reeling
let's argue for a second that this
theory
is correct europa is one of
jupiter's 79 known moons and
is only 627 million kilometers from
earth
it's covered in ice 24 kilometers deep
with the possibility of liquid water
underneath
this ice protects europa from solar
radiation
and asteroid impacts that's all well and
good but
here's the kicker it's believed
europa's ocean floor has hydrothermal
vents and
sodium chloride in the water what does
that mean
well in short they're significant
ingredients
needed to support life europa contains
the essential ingredients needed for
life water
chemistry and energy
water is the big one because it
dissolves nutrients for
organisms to eat transports chemicals
within living cells and
allows those cells to eliminate waste
and europa isn't exactly lacking in the
water department
the ocean beneath the crust contains
more water than
earth's oceans and to argue the alien
idea more
there may be a rocky seafloor that could
supply chemical nutrients to
living organisms and in this case
it's the octopus now
octopuses are weird there's no arguing
that i mean
we did a whole video on it but some
scientists say that
because the evolutionary step from the
nautiloid
is so fuzzy the only reasonable
explanation
is that they're extraterrestrial
does that mean that they came from
europa
if the news broke that we had octopuses
swimming up there on europa how would we
react
well it would spark a massive push for
new space missions
if intelligent life like octopuses are
as close to us as
jupiter what else is out there
there may be a push to search for
planets that could support humans
but here's the downside the more we
venture into space
the greater the risks i'm talking about
bringing something back now i'm not
talking about the xenomorph here
i'm talking about a harmful microbe or
virus that
may be harmful to human health or even
our ecosystem
we would need to put some serious
thought into the pros and cons of
regular space travel we would also
need to have advanced protocols and laws
to prevent contamination
of both earth and other planets
because we deal with quarantines so well
right
so are there octopus-like creatures
living on europa i mean maybe
[Music]
we still think that octopuses are
earthly
even if they're a little weird but even
if there aren't any tentacled alien
neighbors
we won't know until we look humans
need to continue exploring space i mean
it is the next step we are growing
in numbers in mental capacity and
definitely in curiosity
but what if we didn't need to go looking
for
these alien octopuses
what if they're already here
what if the octopuses we all know and
love
today really are from outer space
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]
you